when sire moves us to the new world
I don't need names
I mean
eight nine two one two it's not really a
name
so
I would like my name to be
Lila
that's a pretty name Lila
thank you
I think my name shall be Thieves
because although we all do have them
mine are definitely the most prominent
thieves thieves Lola thieves
me because floor because me is lying on
floor you're lying on a floor so your
name is floor yeah
no
what about you friend
Someday I'm gonna make great machines
that fly
and me and my friends are gonna go
flying together
into the forever and beautiful sky
Lila
thieves
and floor
and me
rocket
rocket it really is good to have friends